[Music]
straight ahead on law on crime daily
security footage shows what happened
inside the deadly yuvaldi school
shooting
and amber heard's motion for a mistrial
is denied after an issue with juror 15
plus more than one year after a mother
and son are found murdered will charges
soon be filed in the murdoch murder
mystery and later the inmate who once
sparked a nationwide manhunt is now
being charged in the death of the
corrections officer who he ran off with
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer for the
first time we're getting a look inside
rob elementary school as police respond
to a deadly shooting in uvalde texas it
happened back in may when an 18 year old
gunman opened fire at the elementary
school 19 students and two teachers were
killed in the massacre the gunman was
also killed 17 others were injured in
the days following the shooting spree
law enforcement faced public scrutiny
for their failure to react quickly
reports say it took more than one hour
for police to take down the shooter as
multiple 911 calls were made from inside
the school and several students inside
yelled to police who were just outside
on tuesday texas tv station kvue and
newspaper austin american statesman
obtained surveillance video from inside
the school we want to warn you the
footage is graphic and may be triggering
to some
hello
as the security footage continues
officers can be seen entering the school
where they remain for more than an hour
officers now face additional scrutiny as
one can be seen checking his cell phone
during the standoff and another later
uses hand sanitizer
joining us today is legal analyst
richard schoenstein and co-host terry
austin
richard hand sanitizing checking their
phones waiting with shields as they hear
children screaming again and again this
new video is revealing troubling facts
but what can be done legally with this
video now that it's released
well brian i think this video can be
used as evidence if someone wants to
bring a negligence claim against the
city or the state for the response to
this terrible terrible incident i hope
also people will consider it when they
address the narrative that the thing to
fight a bad guy with a gun is a good guy
with a gun
because here we had a whole hallway full
of good guys with guns
vests shields other good guys and they
couldn't do anything and before we go
putting guns in the hand of teachers we
ought to consider if a well-armed and
well-trained police officer can't do it
how could we expect a teacher to do it
richard i would agree with that and i'll
add one more point as well years of
training
all of them had that and still they did
not go in terry many of the parents say
they were blindsided by the release of
the video what are your thoughts about
the parents not seeing the video before
the public
you know these parents have already gone
through multiple traumas and having to
see this 77 minute video before it was
brought to their attention before they
had a chance to prepare themselves it
was leaked to the media and it was
shared by these two media outlets and it
was video from security cameras body
cameras cell phone 9-1-1 it had to be
very difficult as a parent i can't even
imagine having to see this on social
media before you actually had a chance
to view it the mayor himself also was
very upset that this happened no one
should have to go through this type of
incident or see it before they had a
chance to prepare themselves absolutely
of course our thoughts go out to the
parents and the families
of these ones who've lost so much
and switching now to colorado as jurors
hear the police interrogation footage
with one of the witnesses in the double
homicide case of kevin dean eastman a
man on trial for the killings of his
ex-girlfriend and her new love interest
two years ago eastman is charged with
two counts of first-degree murder
tampering with a deceased human body and
tampering with physical evidence for
allegedly killing heather frank and
local musician stanley scott sessions
authorities say they were killed on
separate days in february of 2020. frank
and eastman both had arrest warrants in
connection to sessions murder before
frank's body was found prosecutors say
eastman slit session's throat in frank's
apartment and that eastman fatally shot
frank in the chest twice to silence the
only witness to sessions killing they
say he then hit her body on the property
of his new employer troy bonnell who
testified this week investigators say
eastman burned sessions body and was
allegedly preparing to burn frank's body
when he was arrested at a nearby gas
station the jury witnessed the moment in
the police interrogation video when
bonnell was told of frank's body being
on his property
so here's the thing um you know i get i
get improv i know it feels like i've
been solving for time here and i have a
little bit um because sometimes i get
information that i'm not allowed to
share and i gotta wait until they let me
share it okay um so
when they were doing the surgery
property they did find a body what yes
sir
um and where
i that i'm not sure obviously i wasn't
there i've been here with you but they
offered
that uh
they found a body out on your property
they believe as a female so obviously
you know what we're thinking
um
that's heather uh
and
um so that's jesus
christ
yeah
i could see if i was in your position
i'd be pissed too like
i deserve this i'm sure i'm glad you're
beyond tired but hopefully that helps
you to understand
why i need your help
still ahead on law and crime daily
charges could soon be filed in the
murdoch murder mystery out of south
carolina but first amber heard's hopes
for a mistrial are dashed when a
virginia judge denies her motion
[Music]
welcome back a virginia judge denies
amber hearn's motion for a mistrial days
after the actress says she didn't
receive a fair trial due to confusion
with a juror
on wednesday judge penny asked karate
denied all of herds motions citing quote
no evidence of fraud or wrongdoing
related to juror number 15. last week
juror 15 made headlines as herd's team
claimed he improperly served on the jury
while judge azkarati ruled the juror's
name would be temporarily sealed heard's
attorneys say the juror who took in part
in the trial has the same last name as
the person called and lives at the same
address heard's attorneys argued her due
process rights were violated because of
this in court documents file judge as
karate notes major voidier was completed
appropriately and juror 15 accurately
filled out his jury questionnaire all
this comes one month after a virginia
jury ruled largely in favor of johnny
depp awarding the movie star 15 million
dollars in damages stemming from the
defamation case the jury awarded her to
only two million dollars in compensatory
damages
terry if the judge says no fraud or no
wrongdoings then what does that mean
about herd's claim
well judge escaradi essentially denied
that motion denied the claim and the
jury claim will be dropped juror 15 is
free to go there's not going to be a
hearing there's not going to be any
evidence because the judge said that
there is nothing there no prejudice
judge agreed that the due process was
served here that the jury was properly
vetted this particular juror was
properly vetted he sat for the entire
trial he listened to all of the evidence
he took his oath he took his oath
seriously and the judge went on further
to say that she is actually bound by the
jurors decision and so if that jury had
unanimous decisions and they voted the
way they did then she can't undo that
for something like this some small
mistake that caused no prejudice so the
claim is going to be dismissed and we'll
see if herd's team comes up with
anything else yeah richard with all
motions denied
what's next i guess not necessarily
what's next this is my better question
is this the last we're going to hear
about depp and heard or is there more to
come out of this case
oh this is not the last i think this
show is going to keep playing we are off
to appeal now i think
i would expect what i would call a
kitchen sink style appeal where she and
her lawyers raise every issue they can
come up with about the jury and the
evidence and the motions and the judge
and the trial but here's the thing they
got to come up with a bond they have to
post almost an 11 million dollar bond
for the for the verdict in order to
proceed with that appeal so that would
be the big question there but if they
can come up with the money i expect an
appeal
all right we'll see how this plays out
not the last i guess we're going to hear
of this case and in other celebrity news
twitter is suing tesla ceo and spacex
founder elon musk after he announced
he's backing out of a deal to purchase
the social media platform musk made the
move in april to purchase twitter for 44
billion dollars saying the site was
limiting free speech he said he wanted
to take the company private arguing he
would be able to grow twitter and make
it more politically neutral musk and his
lawyers say he's decided to back out of
the deal accusing twitter of withholding
information about the number of spam and
bot accounts on the platform in the
merger twitter and musk had an agreement
that either would pay a one billion
dollar breakup fee if they were
responsible for the deal falling through
musk and his attorneys will have to
prove twitter breached the agreement in
order to not pay that fine twitter says
musk's reversal of the deal caused
irreparable harm to the platform and
wrecked havoc on its stock price twitter
alleges musk operated in bad faith
saying he requested company information
to potentially start a twitter
competitor the social media site filed
the lawsuit in delaware where business
disputes between corporations are
frequently handled
coming up on law and crime daily once an
inmate on the run casey white is
indicted for the death of the
corrections officer who he escaped with
plus the murdoch murder mystery what
charges we could soon expect for
disgraced attorney alec murdock
[Music]
welcome back south carolina attorney
alec murdock is soon expected to be
indicted on murder charges for the 2021
shooting deaths of his wife and son
maggie and paul murdock who is already
behind bars is currently facing more
than 80 counts of fraud and other
charges for allegedly scamming former
clients out of more than 8 million
authorities also accused murdoch of
defrauding the family of his former
housekeeper of more than 4 million
settlement after she died in alleged
slip and fall accident at his home in
june last year murdoch made national
news when he said he came home to find
his wife and 22 year old son who was
facing charges of his own related to a
fatal boat accident shot dead on the
family 1700 acre property little scrapes
attorney made headlines again when he
allegedly hired a hitman to kill him so
his surviving son buster could benefit
from a 10 million dollar life insurance
payout his most recent charges also
include money laundering as part of an
alleged drug trafficking ring as murdoch
had reportedly suffered from an opioid
addiction for years several media
outlets reports south carolina law
enforcement department agents met with
murdoch's family this week to inform
them of the coming murder charges
officials have not released any details
as to what evidence has now led them to
charge murdock in the slangs murdock has
pled not guilty to all charges filed
against him so far and he remains jailed
on a seven million dollar bond
terry how exactly does a grand jury work
and what should we expect when they are
done
you know what brian as a matter of state
law most states have some form of grand
jury and their function really is to
examine the evidence they can do that
with documents they can do that with
witnesses and they have to determine
whether or not there's reasonable cause
to hold a criminal defendant over for
trial in south carolina the grand jury
can issue subpoenas for documents and
they can actually compel witnesses to
testify in connection with the
investigation now usually the accused
does not go and present evidence and
hear that probably will be the case and
at the end of the process there's a true
bill that's issued in south carolina and
that will show whether or not there is
probable cause that a crime's been
committed and that that crime has been
committed by the actual person accused
so that's what the process will look
like here in south carolina so we'll see
what happens yeah richard terry touched
on just a bit but murdoch could testify
in the grand jury he could give his so
to speak two cents as to what happened
but do you think that's wise for him
based on this case and how many open
cases he has
yeah i'd be really surprised brian to
see him testify i mean this guy has a
morass of legal issues he has so many
things ongoing and up in the air he's
not going to want to testify unless he
absolutely has to and unless he has
something absolutely great to say i mean
if he had an ironclad alibi for this and
wanted to offer it to the grand jury i
could see that but short of that i don't
think he's going to open his mouth until
he absolutely has to and maybe not even
then yeah and if he does testify and
they don't believe that he did commit
this crime it's called a grand jury
blowout and he actually has the charges
dismissed and whether or not south
carolina wants to reinvestigate and
recharge him that's the other question
but it's a lot riding on that but i
agree with you unlikely he's going to
testify well also in south carolina the
tiger kings star known as doc antle
appears in federal court on charges of
money laundering bhagavan anto whose
real name is kevin rose to fame at the
height of the kovan 19 pandemic when he
was featured on the netflix docu-series
tiger king anto was featured as an
animal trainer and zoo operator and
owner of a wildlife park in myrtle beach
south carolina last month anto was
arrested by the fbi and charged with
laundering more than half a million
dollars prosecutors say the money came
from a smuggling operation that brought
people across the mexican border into
the united states anto was later
released on 250 000 bond if convicted he
could spend 20 years behind bars anto
also faces separate virginia state
charges in connection to animal cruelty
and wildlife trafficking
when we come back the inmate who escaped
with a correction officer is now
indicted in her death still ahead we
turn to alabama for the case of vicki
and casey white
welcome back in florida a series of
motion hearings continue in the days
leading up to the parkland school
shooting penalty phase right now opening
statements are expected to be presented
next monday july 18th in the case after
pleading guilty last october the
parkland school shooter now faces a
penalty phase trial in which a jury of
his peers will determine whether he
receives life in prison or the death
penalty on february 14 2018 the then 19
year old gunman opened fire at marjory
stoneman douglas high school 17 people
were killed and 17 more injured after a
string of delays the penalty phase is
expected to begin soon ahead of that
judge elizabeth shreer has heard a
series of motions over the past few
weeks as both sides fight for evidence
to be included or excluded from the
coming case on monday prosecutors noted
what they believe are inaccuracies in a
psychological report about the shooter
as prosecutors jeff marcus explains one
report noted that at age 12 the
defendant couldn't understand 50 words
by comparison a separate report notes
that at age six he understood the
complexity of beliefs around life and
death
when
mr cruz's father died he was nearly six
years of age miss browd stated that
when she
saw
the defendant right after the death
he asked her
is my father going to heaven or hell and
he was not yet six years of age
so clearly someone who could not even
form 50 words
at 12 years old at less than 6
wasn't going to be able to understand
concepts of heaven and hell and
articulate such a sentence and miss
browd
articulated
many more words than that that he that
he was aware of so it's clear
that
the vineland answer
which was
that he did not understand 50 words at
12 years of age is an incorrect answer
and an alabama inmate is indicted in the
death of a corrections officer months
after the parent led investigators on an
11-day chase across multiple states as
long crime daily reported inmate casey
white and corrections officer vicki
white were last seen leaving the
lauderdale county jail in alabama
investigators say the pair was not
related but believe they developed a
romantic relationship while spending
time together the couple was on the run
for days sparking a nationwide manhunt
that ended in evansville indiana where
surveillance video caught casey white on
camera at a car wash after that the pair
led authorities on a high-speed chase
that ended in a crash according to the
u.s marshals service casey white emerged
from the crash saying quote please help
my wife she just shot herself in the
head and i didn't do it vicki white
later died in the hospital officials now
say casey white has been indicted for
felony murder alleging that while
committing first-degree escape he caused
the death of vicki white at the time of
his escape casey white was already
serving a 75-year prison sentence he
also faces a separate capital murder
charge
richard why do you think the prosecution
is charging casey white with felony
murder and not murder and doesn't make
sense
it makes sense to me i mean i think they
don't think that casey white pulled the
trigger so the felony murder rule is
invoked when somebody dies while the
defendant is committing a dangerous
felony and it's not the intent of the
defendant to cause the death but it
happens as a proximate result of the
crime that's being committed so what
they're saying is she killed herself in
the course of their flight i've never
seen the felony murder rule applied to a
suicide like this so it's going to be
really interesting but i understand the
theory yeah it's going to be interesting
to see how they say that her suicide was
caused by him but terry casey was
already serving 75 years in jail should
we expect to trial in this case or do
you think he will just take a plea deal
from the prosecution
well you know i think we might see a
trial just because this is such a
heinous situation he's already in jail
he's escaping from jail the person he's
escaping with is now dead but having
said that this case is ripe for a plea
deal as you said he's already awaiting
trial on capital murder charges and
that's for killing 58 year old connie
ridgway it was a stabbing back in 2015.
that trial is expected to come up in
december and he's already serving a
75-year prison sentence he's in his late
30s and so no matter what he's going to
be in jail and that sentence is for
convictions of robbery he went on this
crime spree and attempted to kill his
ex-girlfriend so this is really a plea
deal if they do one that would make
complete sense because what's the point
of spending all the time effort and
money on a trial when we already have
this person serving 75 years and he's
coming up for another death and another
trial for the killing of connie ridgeway
so we'll see what happens but that makes
sense yeah it's gonna be interesting to
see who watches him while those cases
are pending well thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you